de comunidad.
Nos revelan algo sobre la creatividad,
sobre nuestro ingenio,
incluso dejan entrever nuestra identidad.
Y cuando fallan
o se destruyen en un conflicto,
las comunidades pasan dificultades,
no hay desarrollo, los pueblos sufren.
Aun hoy en día
hay más de mil millones de personas en comunidades rurales pobres
en todo el mundo
que no siempre tienen un acceso seguro
a las cosas que nosotros damos por sentado:
educación, cuidados sanitarios, acceso a los mercados.
Por eso organizaciones maravillosas como Puentes a la Prosperidad
construyen puentes en estos sitios... esto es Ruanda.
Hacen una gran diferencia
no solo para los que viven cerca del puente,
sino que el impacto es gigantesco
y se extiende a toda la comunidad
e incluso más allá.
Los puentes han existido desde hace mucho tiempo.
Los más antiguos eran de piedra porque es un material muy duradero.
No sé Uds., pero a mí me encanta estudiar el desarrollo tecnológico
para aprender acerca de lo que se hacía
con los materiales y las herramientas disponibles en cada época.
El Puente del Gard es un ejemplo magnífico
--un acueducto romano en el sur de Francia--
una fantástica obra de tecnología construida con piedras gigantescas,
unidas entre sí sin emplear argamasa.
Son solo piedras unidas...
fantástico
y aún sigue en pie, como nuevo.
A veces, en las montañas,
la gente construye puentes colgantes
que atraviesan un cañón profundo
usando vid.
Este es en Perú.
Aquí usan hierbas que crecen localmente
y se tejen como cuerdas para construir estos puentes.
¿Sabían que lo reconstruyen todos los años?
Porque la hierba no es un material duradero.
No ha cambiado desde el tiempo de los Incas.
Los puentes pueden llegar a ser un símbolo del sitio.
El Golden Gate y el de Sídney son muy conocidos.
En Mostar, el puente era sinónimo con la ciudad
hasta el punto que, cuando fue destruido en la guerra de 1993,
la ciudad perdió su identidad hasta que el puente fue reconstruido.
Los puentes son objetos enormes en nuestros paisajes
--claro, también los hay pequeños--
pero son objetos realmente importantes
por lo que creo que es nuestro deber construir puentes hermosos.
Por suerte, muchos lo son.
Piensen en el impresionante Viaducto de Millau en el sur de Francia.
El ingeniero francés Michel Virlogeux y el arquitecto inglés Lord Foster
trabajaron juntos para producir una obra
que es una sinergia espectacular entre arquitectura e ingeniería.
O el puente de Salginatobel de Robert Maillart en las montañas suizas...
realmente sublime.
O más recientemente,
el hermoso y delicado puente de Laurent Ney
para el castillo Tintagel en el Reino Unido.
Son obras espectaculares y hermosas
y necesitamos que haya más.
Los puentes pueden clasificarse convenientemente en tres categorías
dependiendo de la naturaleza del sistema estructural
que adoptan como su soporte principal.
La flexión, claro, es la manera como se comporta la viga...
así que viga y flexión.
O la compresión, que es el principio en el que se basa un arco.
O para tramos muy largos que deben ser livianos,
como verán en un minuto,
se usa la tensión, los cables...
puentes colgantes.
Y las oportunidades para variar son enormes.
Los ingenieros tienen un gran potencial
para la innovación, el ingenio
y el desarrollo de formas diferentes alrededor de estos tipos de puente.
Pero los cambios tecnológicos en mi campo son relativamente lentos
aunque Uds. no lo crean,
en comparación a los cambios que ocurren en la tecnología del teléfono móvil,
las computadoras, las tecnologías digitales, etc.
En el mundo de la construcción
los cambios ocurren de manera extremadamente lenta.
Y la razón se puede resumir en una palabra:
riesgo.
Los ingenieros estructurales gestionamos el riesgo.
Nuestro trabajo es estar a cargo de la seguridad estructural.
Cuando diseñamos puentes como estos,
hay que considerar la probabilidad de que la carga sea excesiva, por un lado,
y por otro la probabilidad de que la resistencia sea insuficiente.
Dos cosas que, por otra parte, suelen estar llenas de incertidumbre
así que es un problema probabilístico y tenemos que asegurarnos
de que haya un margen de seguridad adecuado entre las dos, por supuesto.
Tengo que decirles que la seguridad absoluta
no existe.
Contrario a la creencia popular
el riesgo nulo no existe.
Los ingenieros tienen que hacer sus cálculos correctamente
para asegurar esos márgenes,
y la sociedad espera que así lo hagan,
por eso es tan alarmante cuando ocurren hechos como estos.
No voy a ahondar sobre las causas de estas tragedias,
pero son parte de la razón
por la que el cambio tecnológico ocurre de forma tan lenta.
Nadie quiere que ocurra esto.
Los clientes no quieren que esto les ocurra a sus proyectos, obvio,
sin embargo quieren innovación.
La innovación es vital.
Como ingeniero, es parte de mi ADN.
Está en mi sangre.
No sería un buen ingeniero si no quisiera innovar,
pero debemos hacerlo desde una posición sólida,
con un buen conocimiento de la situación.
No podemos caminar en la oscuridad
y las civilizaciones han aprendido de sus errores desde los comienzos...
especialmente los ingenieros.
Quizá hayan visto antes esta filmación --
es del famoso puente de Tacoma Narrows
que colapsó en Tacoma, en el estado de Washington,
en 1940.
Fue conocido como la "Galopante Gertrudis",
porque ella --¿ella?--
¿es un puente femenino? No sé.
El puente se tambaleó así durante un buen tiempo;
observen este movimiento de torsión.
El puente era demasiado flexible.
Fue diseñado por Leon Moisseiff,
experto en el diseño de puentes colgantes,
pero aquí se pasó un poco más de los límites y pagó el precio.
Afortunadamente, no hubo víctimas.
Pero el colapso de este puente
detuvo por completo el desarrollo de los puentes colgantes.
Durante 10 años nadie pensó en construir otro puente colgante.
No hubo ninguno.
Y cuando resurgieron, en los años 50, lo hicieron con exageración, obviamente;
unos diseños demasiado seguros, en respuesta a lo que había ocurrido.
Pero cuando finalmente volvieron, en la mitad de la década de los 60,
ya había un cambio profundo,
una innovación, un profundo cambio tecnológico.
Este es el Puente del Severn en el Reino Unido.
Observen la sección, en el centro, aerodinámicamente optimizada.
También es como una caja, lo que le da rigidez a la torsión,
ese retorcimiento que vimos en Tacoma no ocurriría aquí.
También es muy ligero, y enseguida veremos
que eso es muy importante cuando se trata de grandes tramos,
y pareciera que todos quieren puentes con tramos cada vez más grandes.
El récord hoy en día está en Japón,
con un vano de casi 2000 metros.
Casi 2 kilómetros.